c'est un incontournable de la
gastronomie française où l'on célèbre
l'art culinaire
mais aujourd'hui les employés de
l'atelier de joël robuchon sont en deuil
et ses clients sont sous le choc
je suis choqué je viens ici pour manger
chaque fois que je suis à paris
cette revue science et l institution
française c'est vraiment une perte
terrible pour la france pour la france
et pour la planète à travers le monde
les grands chefs pleure la disparition
d'une icône
c'est une triste journée - ce matin le
réveil a été épouvantable
joël robuchon l'homme qui a donné à la
purée de pommes de terre ses lettres de
noblesse au monument de la cuisine avec
un record difficile à battre plus de
trente étoiles au guide michelin
le résultat d'un travail acharné de
perfectionnisme qui lui vaut de se faire
sacrer meilleur cuisinier du siècle par
le guide gault et millau bien des chefs
étoilés aujourd'hui avoue lui de voir
beaucoup ça monsieur qui a des mots le
sens de la qualité d'économies de la
qualité un geste parfait maîtrise
de ce métier exemplaires toujours vêtu
de noir avec des chaussures rouges
joël rebuchon créé une petite révolution
au milieu des tabliers blancs passionnés
de haute cuisine
il s'était aussi donné pour mission de
la démocratiser de l'enseigné
nous allons aider les jeunes d'abord
c'est notre devoir à tous nous avons
aussi nous devons transmettre c'est
aider des jeunes justement en leur
faisant sept
ce passage doit elle rebuchon était
aussi un homme d'affaires à la tête d'un
empire 26 restaurants dans 8 pays
différents à paris londres tokyo et
montréal les ateliers joël robuchon un
concept nouveau inspiré des bars à tapas
où les clients s'assoient au comptoir
pour regarder travailler les cuisiniers
l'atelier le concept de base c'est une
cuisine qui est très gastronomique mais
dans un environnement qui est très
conviviale si joël robuchon n'est plus
son empreinte son influence sur la
gastronomie française sont loin de
disparaître
même chose pour ses entreprises ses
restaurants comme celui ci ne
désemplissent pas et ses petits plats
gastronomiques disponible en épicerie
sont toujours aussi populaires ici jean
françois bélanger radio-canada paris